this I'm not disagreeing with you they
are outliers but you're talking about
our lives
if you wear a condom properly 99.99
you're not gonna get the girl pregnant
so this okay no the thing is we're
talking about mandam here in London
we're talking about Wonderland okay oh
you know what the rubber don't feel
though it doesn't feel good
okay okay but that's but let's let's
take the condom example okay you can say
you cannot have sex with me unless you
have a condom on yeah that women are in
control of sex you're in control and who
has more power the one who is 41 for
wait who has 41 forms of birth control
or the one who's one less more power